mujeres afro si latinos esos son algunos
de los funcionarios que joe biden nombró
este lunes todos trabajaron en la era
obama la primera designación fue la de
anthony blinken como secretario de
estado el nominado para liderar la
diplomacia estadounidense fue el segundo
al mando del departamento y es uno de
los asesores más cercanos de bite en el
departamento de seguridad nacional
estaría alejandro mayorkas este cubano
americano sería el primer latino en ser
el director de la entidad si es
confirmado por el senado y conoce
personalmente la invitación
cuando era muy joven eeuu nos
proporcionó a mi familia ya mí un lugar
de refugio ahora he sido nominado para
ser el director del departamento de
seguridad nacional y supervisar la
protección de todos los estadounidenses
y aquellos que huyen de la persecución
en busca de una mejor vida para ellos y
sus seres queridos
por su parte prior heinz sería la
primera mujer en ser la directora de
inteligencia y la otra mujer del
gabinete es linda thomas winfield quien
sería la embajadora de eeuu ante la onu
y fue la subsecretaria de estado para
asuntos africanos he tenido el
privilegio de entablar relaciones con
líderes de todo el mundo durante los
últimos 35 años como embajadora de eeuu
ante las naciones unidas trabajaré para
restaurar la posición de eeuu en el
mundo y renovar las relaciones con
nuestros aliados bendecida por esta
oportunidad
john kerry entra al gabinete es uno de
los demócratas con más recorrido y ahora
sería el delegado presidencial para que
aunque bailen todavía no ha confirmado
quién liderará el departamento del
tesoro medios estadounidenses apuntan a
janet jagan quien presidió el sistema de
la reserva federal